[Musique]
m two way m2 ayem est une start up donc
qui a été créée en 2015
les intégrateurs de systèmes hi outils
et notamment pour la gestion de
l'éclairage public
[Musique]
le projet pak idowu est un projet
d'innovation airbus cyber security a
travaillé avec saint quentin en yvelines
ainsi que sept autres
sept autres partenaires au travers d'un
cas du visage de d'éclairage intelligent
visant à des capacités de contrôle et
les lampadaires à distance on a mis à
disposition notre savoir et notre
système existant on était à la recherche
d'un partenaire qui connaissait le
fonctionnement des lampadaires
intelligents des systèmes d'éclairage
intelligent pour pouvoir mener cette
expérimentation temps réel ça s'est fait
par l'intermédiaire de sky
puisque nous avions déjà une
expérimentation sur l'éclairage public
c'est comme ça qu'on a rencontré
notamment au travers de l'incubateur de
saint quentin en yvelines le sky cure là
la start-up m2 ayem qui répondait
parfaitement aux critères de technologie
et aussi de réactivité
une collaboration excellente 6ème 2ième
a été extrêmement réactif et nous a
permis de mettre en place ce
démonstrateur rapidement on a bénéficié
de cet environnement d'experts expert
sécurité et aliotti pour pouvoir
vraiment améliorer notre système
c'est un succès technologique aussi on a
ainsi pu établir et construire une
solution d'éclairage intelligent
hautement sécurisé ça nous a permis de
gagner en maturité et de progresser d'un
point de vue sécurité